denmark has announced it will eliminate
the country's entire population of
farmed
minks after mutated coronavirus strains
were reported among the animals
more than 15 million will be called in
some cases the mutated virus
also infected people medical experts
fear
that could jeopardize the effectiveness
of future coveted vaccines
there are more than 1300 mink farms in
denmark
many of them are in the municipality of
jochem including bjarna paterson's
the virus reached his farm in early
september
he clearly remembers that day
it was like a wave passing through the
stables
it began at one end with the animals
sneezing and losing their appetite
and it kept spreading but
one week later on the following weekend
it was over
the animals were healthy again
[Music]
also contracted the virus now to be on
the safe side
all of his 10 000 mink will be called
he never imagined that denmark's mink
farms could develop into hot spots
it is thought that the coronavirus stems
from the animal world
it is believed to have first jumped from
a bad species to humans
via the pangolin in china on denmark's
mink farms
it is now jumping back to animals from
humans
once a mink is infected the virus
spreads to almost all of the animals
on a farm in less than two weeks
virologists are concerned about this
extensive transmission
anders fromsguards team analyzed the
mutation on the mink farms
and found it matched the virus found in
some people in the region who fell ill
we can see exactly how the virus spreads
it comes from humans it is transmitted
to minks
where it spreads on mass and mutates in
a manner we don't see in humans
and then it jumps back to the human
population and thus to the rest of the
world
every third corona case in northern
youth land can already be traced back to
the mink farms
exactly how it spread is still unclear
but with ever more mutations in
circulation
especially those from animals the
pandemic will become difficult to stop
a vaccine could lose its effectiveness
and the people who have been ill
might not be immune to the mutation so
we would never achieve herd immunity
and that is why culling task forces are
now rapidly traveling through denmark
the animals are killed with carbon
monoxide in boxes like this one
they're then immediately incinerated
along with their valuable fur
protective gear is mandatory as any
animal might be infected
we didn't hear god everybody we have to
kill 39 000 minks on this farm
we'll be busy for two and a half days we
have 30 workers
five vets and a standby team of five to
ten men here
they will need at least another four
weeks to work their way to all the farms
a total of 160 farms are affected and
there are suspicious cases on many more
millions of minks have yet to be called